[Music]
we welcome you back to cbs this morning
we are continuing our conversation with
oprah we've got another exclusive
excerpt
from her interview last night with
prince harry and megan it's a doozy
if you missed any of these new clips you
can watch all of them right now on cbs
this morning's twitter
and youtube accounts we'll actually
watch it starting at nine o'clock
eastern
so oprah in this unaired excerpt megan
and harry discuss feeling not supported
by the royal family from attacks
in the uk tabloids and they say the
attacks on them were different
because of race you remember this one
let's listen
you've had these conversations with your
family members they know why you left
so has anybody said i'm sorry you had to
make that move or i'm sorry you felt
that you had to do that because you
felt we were not supporting you
no sadly not the the
the feeling is that this was our
decision therefore the consequences on
us
um and despite three years of
of asking for help and seeing or or
visualizing how this might end
it was i don't know i just it was it's
been it's
look it's been really hard because i'm
trying
i am part of i'm part of the system
with with them i always have been um
but i guess there is i'm very aware of
this that
my brother can't leave that system but i
have
does your brother want to leave the
system i don't know i can't speak for
him
but with that relationship
and that that that control and the fear
by the
by the uh by the uk um tabloids it's a
really
it's a toxic environment um but i will
always be there for him i will always be
there for my family and i
as i said i've tried to help them to see
what has happened
do they think it's a toxic environment
or do you all just think it's a toxic
environment because you're now out of it
do if we were to have an interview with
them or a conversation with them
does your father think it's a toxic
environment or relationship
he's had to make peace with it and why
couldn't you make
peace with it i'll ask that of both of
you because this was different
you know no difference because different
because of the race and social media
and social media oh yes different time
that didn't exist and so
it was like the wild wild west it was
spread like wildfire plus
by being american it translated in a
different way across
the pond so you had a noise level that
was
very different but if they can't see
that it's different
so you felt bullied on an international
level
look i think the i think the volume of
what was coming in and the interest
was greater because of social media
because of the fact that i was not just
british
um and that unfortunately
if members of his family say well this
is what's happened to all of us or if
you know if
if they can compare what the experience
that i went through was similar to
what has been shared with us kate was
called weighty katie
waiting to marry william while i imagine
that was really hard and i do i can't
picture what that felt like this is not
the same
and if a member of his family will
comfortably say we've all had to deal
with things that are rude
rude and racist are not the same and
equally
you've also had a press team that goes
on the record to defend you
especially when they know something's
not true and that didn't happen for us
you mentioned earlier harry that you
were hurt by the fact that
there's been no acknowledgement on the
part of your family
that this was different because of
race do you think there ever will be
and would that make a difference to you
yeah it would make a huge difference
um you know they said
there's a lot of people that have
seen it for what it was yeah yeah
a lot of people like it's talked about
across the world
yet the very people that don't want to
see it or can't see it
choose not to see it wow boy
oprah when he said when when megan said
rude and racist are not the same i
thought that was a
very powerful statement and i'm curious
about your reaction too
yeah your reaction when you saw that and
the other thing that i'm hearing already
chatter bubbling up is if these two want
privacy why are they sitting down with
the queen of
american television i think there's a
difference between privacy and intrusion
could you talk about that from their
point of view and what you thought yes
we said rude
racist well i i thought that was really
very powerful
and i also you know thought that she was
gracious
when speaking about what happened with
kate milt
middleton in terms of you know weighty
katie
they are not the same and i think
um what anthony said earlier i don't
think the american public understands
that we tr we attempted to but weren't
really able to
show you what the barrage of daily
vitriol uh and negativity
on a regular basis on a consistent basis
does to your personal psyche i mean it
wasn't just like a couple of stories
it's a business and she's a commodity
and an asset to that business and so
what uh
the point that they made in the
interview that we weren't able to show
is that yes they want privacy
but they understand that they are public
figures and the privacy is to not to be
intruded upon
right the same thing everybody else in
the world wants and that there is a
difference between
privacy and intrusion and being able to
have boundaries
yes you want privacy you don't want
helicopters and people hiding in the
bushes
filming your baby outside playing and
um i think that when people say oh
they're talking now and they wanted
privacy
they don't understand that there is a
difference between
being a public figure who wants to have
some boundaries and not to be
consistently intruded upon versus
being private yeah or or and also please
tell the truth
i've heard one example of okay i'll
share one photo with you say on
instagram it doesn't mean i want you to
have the whole role
and it was a non-stop of negative press
that was not true
hey oprah i'm curious i mean there were
so many there were so many
bombshells in this interview i mean it
seemed like one after another
was there was there anyone that
especially surprised you
uh i think the skin tone the co the
discussions about
uh what color what what archie's skin
tone would be
that surprised me what also surprised me
was and that's why i clarified
were you just feeling badly were you
feeling sad
or were there actual suicidal ideation
thoughts of harming yourself that also
uh
really surprised me oprah i just want to
clarify once it surprised me that harry
said he was trapped
yeah yeah surprised me that harry said
he said he was trapped and when i said
how are you trapped if you're in a
palace and then he came back at me like
yes but i also thought it was very
interesting that he added that he felt
his father and his brother were trapped
too
yeah he made a point he was very
specific but he was there oprah we're
running out of time but i want to
clarify when you say you were surprised
about the skin tone conversation
were you surprised that that would be
true inside the palace or were you
surprised they were telling you about it
i was surprised that they were telling
me about it
[Music]
i mean i i think that's when the first
jaw dropped for a lot of people and it's
it's generating a lot of you know even i
yeah
guys even i on the tape you could hear
me go whoa because i'm like i cannot
even believe
you are saying this right now but i
think it speaks to
them talking to you and how comfortable
they felt we'll get more about that too
oprah stay with us we're going to take a
quick break